قصتي مع الاعتقال طويله
ولنقول انها بدات يعني من بدايه الشباب
معروف الوضع السياسي في سوريا الوضع
المضطرب والانقلابات العسكريه
والديكتاتوريات العسكريه التي تاتي بعد
الانقلابات العسكريه
والقمع الذي يمارس على الشعب السوري طبعا
يعني ما قبل السبعين يمكن الحديث عن قمع
ذو سويه ماء ورد السبعين السويه تختلف
من البدايه كوني مهتم بالشان العام ودائما
اهتمامات السياسيه
وعلى الاغلب معارض لكل الانظمه
الديكتاتوريه التي تعاقبت على سوريا
فدائما كنت اتعرض
المساءله والاعتقال كمنت من الى حزب او
تنظيم معين كساري بشكل عام يعني احيانا
حتى لم اكن منتميا لاي تنظيم ولكن
لنقل اني اجاهد
معارضا برايه ضد السلطات الحاكمه اكيد
سيتعرض للمسائل وسيتعرض للاعتقال يعني قبل
الاعتقال الكبير الاخير كم مره كنت اعتقلت
سابقا اعتقلت اربعه خمس مرات لكن قبل
السبعين كانت المسائل
اسهل بكثير وتاخذ مساله ايام او اسبوع
اسبوعين ويتم الافراج عن المعتقد كما حصل
معك لاحقا قد يحصل بعض التعذيب او التهديد
يعني لا يتعدى الضرب على الاجرين يعني
بيسموها بسوريا الفلقه
لكن بعد السبعين طبعا يختلف الامر تماما
يعني فعدد
من استدعاءات والاعتقالات يعني عديد لكن
بعد السبعين اعتقلت مرتين
مره في 79 واستمر الاعتقال تقريبا سنه
خرجنا في الثمانين
والمره الثانيه في اخر 81
استمر 13 سنه فكان المجموع حوالي 14 سنه
اعتقاد تجربتي الشخصيه هي فقط لانتمائي
لحزب سياسي معارض للنظام ويطالب باسقاط
الديكتاتوريه العسكريه
الشخص صديقي اللي هو الجزء الثاني او
المكون الاخر
اعتقل بسبب لنقل
تقرير اصدقائه واحد اصدقائه بفرنسا وعند
عودته الى سوريا من المطار تم اعتقاله وهو
مسيحي وبتهمه الاخوان المسلمين يعني
تقريبا نفس ظروفك نفس الاعتقال نفس
الاعتقان
سواء بالتحقيق او بالحياه اليوميه او
بالمضيق او بالحرمان او
حرمان من الزيارات حرمه رؤيه الاهل كل هذا
يعني
ما يسري عليه يسري عليه يسري على جميع
المعتقلين التي خاضوا تجربه تدمر وصيدنايا
والفروع اعطيتني من السؤال الذي يلي لانه
كان سؤالي عن الخلط الذي حصل لدى البعض
بين ما يخصك شخصيا وما يخص البطل الاخر
الذي لا نراه ولا نسمعه عمليا في هذه
الروايه الا في خفايا السطور هو وضعه كثير
خاص وانا استاذنته قلت اجري دمج بين
تجربتك وتجربتي
وساستعير هذه المفارقه الحاده بانه يتم
اعتقال شخص مسيحي بتهمه اخوان مسلمين يعني
ايوه في بلد مثل سوريا
فقط هو طلب مني وعد شرف ام لا ادلي باي
معلومه قد تؤدي اليه لانه لا زال يعيش في
سوريا